There is a story that's hugely important but
not necessarily for the reasons a lot of people
think.
The Chinese doctor who was the whistle blower
about Corona virus has died now immediately
a ton of articles and a ton of people started
saying or implying the Chinese government
killed the doctor and that that's the scandal.
The doctor appears to have genuinely died
of Corona virus himself, which he contracted
while working at [inaudible] central hospital
in China.
The scandal and the controversy is that the
Chinese government appears to have sent police
to tell him to shut up about Corona virus
after he sent out a warning via chat group
to other doctors on December 30th about Corona
virus.
We're talking about 34 year old.
Dr. Lee wen Liang, who was an ophthalmologist,
noticed seven cases of a virus that looked
to him like SARS.
He sent a message to doctors in a chat group
saying, you should wear protective clothing
when you're with patients.
Four days later, as reported by the BBC.
He was summoned by the public security Bureau
where he was told to sign a letter which,
uh, accused him of quote making false comments
that had quote severely disturbed the social
order.
He was one of eight people who police say
were being investigated for spreading rumors.
Local authorities later apologized to him
because of course he was completely right
about Corona virus, but more importantly,
a few days later on 10th he started coughing.
Then he had a fever.
Then he was in the hospital, diagnosed with
Corona virus on the 30th of January and ultimately
has passed away.
So as of right now, I do not believe that
the Chinese government killed him.
I believe he died of exactly what he was worried
about, which is Corona virus contracted from
patients.
The real concern is that the Chinese government
has prioritized silencing doctors rather than
immediately moving to deal with Corona virus.
And I want to be really careful because the
entire Corona virus story has been used in
some enclaves to justify discriminatory and
disgusting comments about Chinese people and
Chinese culture.
That's not what I'm doing.
This is a critique of the Chinese government.
Now, just to circle back around to the conspiracy
theory piece, that the Chinese government
killed this guy to silence him, that he didn't
die of Corona viruses of go of Corona virus.
I'm not blind to the atrocities committed
by the Chinese government over the last many
decades.
I'm not pretending they don't exist.
We don't have evidence that that's what happened.
So I don't believe that it is prudent or responsible
to push it.
Now, there are some people who said, you know,
this guy was 34 Corona virus is really killing
little kids in the elderly.
How did a 34 year old die of it?
That's mostly true, but there are people of
just sort of medium ages that have died of
Corona virus.
I'm not ignoring the possibility that there
is more to this, but right now it does not
seem responsible to push that the Chinese
government killed this guy.
It does seem that the Chinese government was
more concerned with covering up the existence
of Corona virus early on than in moving quickly
and swiftly to actually deal with it.
The latest numbers, 38,000 cases, 815 deaths,
nearly 3000 people have recovered so far.
So far there is a lower death rate with Corona
virus than with SARS.
The death rate is about 2% with SARS it was
about 10 to 15%, but the number of infections
is significantly larger and more than likely
it's going to end up killing many more people.
Very, very sad what's going on.
And certainly anytime a government works to
cover something up rather than to actually
deal with it, it is concerning for the entire
world.
As we are quickly seeing cases start to spread
all over the world.